public health propaganda reached new
heights this past weekend
when brazilian authorities lit up the
very famous statue of christ the
redeemer
in rio de janeiro lit it up
in a line that says vaccine saves
very creepy extremely sacrilegious
and also just not true you know you know
how i know this
i know this with scientific certainty
100
of people who get the vaccine will die
i can i know that and youtube's going to
try to shut me down for that
it is simply a scientific fact 100
of people who get the vaccine will die
now
they're probably not going to die
tomorrow very possibly the vaccine will
extend their lives but they will die
this substitute religion
is ridiculous and so many people these
days
are beginning to tune it out they are
realizing that the public health
establishment
has not only lost its credibility has
not only misled people in so many ways
but it is also grabbing so much power
that it does not deserve
political power and religious power as
well and many many people
are tuning it out i'm michael knowles
it's the michael knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from benjamin watson
who says
the cdc's changes in masking
restrictions is the equivalent to an
employer shouting you're fired
right before their employee quits far
more about maintaining authority and
control than anything else
i think this is pretty true i think this
is pretty
fair that public health officials were
trying to hold onto power trying to
force everyone
to keep distancing keep masking and then
people just ignored them and governors
started ignoring them
so now johnny come lately they said no
actually we wanted you to
to to disregard the masks from the
beginning so keep listening to us
about everything else it's desperate and
it's obviously
political people are recognizing their
rights they're protecting themselves
when you want to protect yourself
and exercise your rights you got to
check out armored
republic you've heard me talk about how
important the second amendment
is to the foundation of our country i'm
going to be getting into it a little bit
more
later in the show you might even be one
of the over 5 million citizens who
purchased a firearm for the first time
in 2020.
if you have taken the first step of
protecting yourself with a firearm
the next step in your personal
protection plan should be considering
body armor for yourself and your family
shopping for body armor may seem like
something that you never thought you'd
have to do i mean i never expected to be
wearing body armor
you may not know where to begin in fact
you may not even know that you could buy
body armor that is where ar
500 armor comes in i really love this
company these guys have their heads on
straight and they make a tremendous
product
that can protect you if things spin out
of control as maybe some of you have
noticed
very well can happen maybe you've
noticed that in recent years best of all
they put together some packages
specifically
for listeners of the daily wire so
something for everyone at ar 500 armor
dot com
head on over to ar500 armor dot com
slash knowles
and see all their promotions and special
pricing running right now you can use
code knowles for 20
off anything else in the entire store
right now
you can plan for how to protect yourself
and your family for the future so get
yourself the body armor that we trust
at ar 500 armor dot com slash knowles
you get 20
off with the code knowles people are
beginning to
tune out if they haven't already they're
certainly now beginning to tune out
the public health propagandists who are
taking a lot of power for themselves
notably eric clapton you know eric
clapton very famous one of the most
famous rock musicians in the world
eric clapton is saying things that could
get him kicked off of youtube
here's what he's saying i'm just going
to report what he's saying because if i
were to say it
i could run the risk of being kicked off
of youtube that is how closely
uh tied in the big tech industry is with
the bureaucracy with the government with
the public health administration so
i'm just going to read what eric clapton
said and his experience of the vaccine
he said quote
i took the first jab of astrazeneca and
right away had severe reactions which
lasted
10 days i recovered eventually and was
told it could be 12 weeks before the
second one
about six weeks later i was offered and
took the second astrazeneca shot
but with a little more knowledge of the
dangers needless to say the reactions
were disastrous
my hands and feet were either frozen
numb or burning
and pretty much useless for two weeks i
feared i would never play again
this guy is one of the most famous
guitarists ever you know
in popular music and so that that's a
very big fear he goes on
i suffer with peripheral neuropathy and
should never have gone near the needle
but the propaganda said the vaccine was
safe for everyone so here's the here's
the issue
okay i am not telling any tales at a
school here okay i'm not saying anything
that is a conspiracy theory or anything
like that remember they paused a vaccine
because there were rare rare rather but
significant
side effects only affected a very small
number of people
but they were very very as significant
as they possibly
can be and you're not really allowed to
talk about that
even when the public health officials
come out and say yes there have been
these rare cases but
we're going to pause certain vaccines
but then we're going to start them again
we the public and especially
communicators are not allowed to mention
this or we're called conspiracy
theorists and we're called anti-vaxxers
or something
and taken off of the internet i'm
nothing of the sort and i'm not even
anti-vaccine generally speaking but i
i do think we should be able to report
on these sorts of reactions a lot of
people
have heard these things anecdotally from
friends or relatives or friends of
friends or in this case
from eric clapton but we're not allowed
to do that
because the scientific matter of the
vaccines is not really considered a
scientific matter
just like the scientific matter of the
coronavirus is not really considered a
scientific matter
it's a political matter whereby public
health officials
will will lie to our faces right they'll
say one day they'll say
don't wear the masks the masks don't
work you shouldn't wear the mask you
stupid sheep
i'm paraphrasing or exalted dr fauci
then five seconds later he says
you have to wear the masks and then
later on he justifies it and says
that he misled us in the first place
because he thought that all of us
peasants would go out and buy up the
masks and he wanted to save them for the
nurses but now that he knows there's
enough masks he's going to tell us that
we need to buy them
okay presuming to take a lot of
political power and in the case of rio
presuming to to take to take the place
of christianity to supplant christianity
in rio for goodness sakes
and and on a very famous statue of
christ the redeemer a statute
that that says christ saves to cover
that up and say no vaccine
saves which is to say the public health
officials
save but there are downsides here okay
as with
any scientific procedure there is a risk
even even now the public health
officials who paused one of the vaccines
will acknowledge yes there are risks and
you've got to make a risk calculation
which is why i've said from the
beginning
if i were older if i were fatter if i
were in poorer health
i would probably be much more likely to
rush out and get the vaccine that i
am now as a relatively young ostensibly
healthy millennial i'm not saying i have
no risk
don't you let if anything ever happens
to me if i get kovid
you know and god forbid something
terrible happens don't you let
the libs write headlines about me that i
was a covid denier and i got my
comeuppance i'm not denying anything i'm
just saying
that people ought to take risks into
account there are downsides to
everything that we do there's no such
thing as a free lunch the uk is seeing
this right now the uk
is now dealing with the downside of the
covid lockdowns other than destroying
the economy and people's political
rights
and shutting down churches and depriving
people of of so many of their traditions
and liberties
here's another downside the even the
public health officials in the uk
are now worried that kids are going to
get more common respiratory infections
at higher rates
with more severe reactions because
they've been locked down for a full year
so in in the united kingdom right now
medical professionals are telling the
sun
the newspaper the models are showing
that beginning this fall there could be
between
twenty percent and fifty percent more
cases of children
needing to be hospitalized from
respiratory
synchricial i don't know i'm
mispronouncing that virus otherwise
known as rsv
which usually causes mild cold-like
symptoms and can be serious
for infants and and senior citizens from
one expert quote
there is a concern that children this
year have missed out on a normal
rsv viral exposure they would normally
be exposed to this
but they won't have been because of
lockdown and other experts said we may
get a big surge of routine respiratory
conditions
this autumn and winter as most people
avoided contact
last winter it's not just kids each year
around 30 000 kids are hospitalized
because of this virus could be
significantly more
this year now i think that i'm going to
be in a pretty good position i think a
lot of you are going to be in a pretty
good position
because from the beginning i've just
ignored the lockdown
i just have i haven't in rare cases such
as on an airplane when they make me wear
the mask i
basically wear the mask the whole time
but otherwise i've ignored it you know
and i've seen my friends and i've seen
my family and i've gone out and i've
flown
all over god's green earth and i
i feel great and so thankfully you know
i made it through just fine this whole
year and i've gotten to see family i've
gotten to live my life
and also now i've exposed myself to the
environment because we do have an immune
system
i know that the public health
professionals want to pretend that
they are the only thing keeping us from
sudden death at any given moment
but there are other things folks we have
our immune system
we have our common sense we have our
prudence we have our actual redeemer
in his providence okay we've got all of
these things and there is more to life
than not coming down with the cough okay
and there are
prudential risk assessments that people
can make we're not allowed to say that
anymore
actually what we're told we have to
believe is that if you don't get
this vaccine immediately regardless of
your age regardless of your
risk level that you are endangering not
just the public you're endangering
yourself
and you will pay the price if the
unvaccinated get vaccinated
they will protect themselves and other
unvaccinated people
around them if they do not states with
low vaccination rates may see
those rates go up may see this progress
reversed
ultimately those who are not vaccinated
will
end up paying the price the vaccinator
will continue to be protected against
severe illnesses but others may not be
if you're not vaccinated
but given that the vaccination is
convenient and free
it'll be a tragedy if it's a needless
one
to see covert cases among those who do
not get vaccinated go up
so what what joe biden has said right
here the unvaccinated will pay the price
that's simply not true if he wanted to
be accurate he would say the
unvaccinated
may pay the price because there's risk
and uncertainty in anything that we do
eric clapton is paying the price and
luckily it's all okay now right
the experts tell us that well we know
there are widespread
mild reactions to the vaccines we all
have a friend or relative who
got the second shot and they were down
for the count for a few days
but in some cases there are more serious
reactions
we are told by the experts that they're
very very rare so i'm not saying don't
get the vaccine
but i am saying there's always a risk in
life and so yeah there's a risk to not
getting the vaccine too
and people may pay the price that's
that's the way this world
works however i think there's a serious
reason to doubt
joe biden here okay namely he's been
wrong about this thing from the
beginning
when texas decided it was going to lift
its mask mandate
this would have been a couple months ago
now joe biden
came out and he said that this was
neanderthal
thinking last thing we need is
neanderthal thinking that
in the meantime everything's fine take
off your mask
forget it yeah that's what we're getting
neanderthal thinking so
i'm sure the cases have skyrocketed
deaths have skyrocketed in texas right
let's see the latest let's check in on
the science um
oh wow that's how about that texas is
reporting
zero deaths from the coronavirus for the
first time now in nearly 14 months this
is months now
after they lifted the mask mandate so
the issue here someone wrote in
to ben's radio show actually when i was
filling in and they said you got to talk
to your friend knowles he's an
anti-vaxxer and he's being selfish
i'm not i'm not an anti-vaxxer i don't
think that my
reticence to rush out and get the
vaccine i don't think it's selfish at
all i don't think the science suggests
that this will in any way harm anybody
else but
the point i will make for the one in
five americans who are a little
skeptical of these vaccines and
the a good portion of them who say they
won't get it under any circumstances
which is a much harsher stance than i
have is
it's not my fault that the public health
administrators squandered their
credibility that's not my fault it's not
my fault that they misled people
and got caught it's not my fault that
their predictions were wrong it's not my
fault that joe biden's predictions were
wrong
that that ain't my fault if they want
credibility they have to earn it
speaking of earning people's trust has
anyone done
done that more so than city journal city
journal a great great outlet to go check
out
if you're interested in learning more
about what's going on in our nation's
cities and in our culture you absolutely
need to be reading city journal
published by the manhattan institute
city journal is the nation's premier
urban policy magazine with fearless
writers such as heather mcdonald love
her
christopher ruffo he's terrific chris
ruffo's work right now is reporting on
the woke
craze and critical race theory that is
going on
in our schools around this country each
issue is designed with beautifully
inspired covers
making it excellent material for your
coffee table your living room or
anywhere else
that you'd like to impress your friends
and family now for a limited time
our listeners can enter for a chance to
get their hands on a print issue of city
journal
the magazine for free just go to
cityhyphenjournal.org
giveaway enter your information and you
will be contacted if you are
selected so head on over right now that
is city hyphen journal
dot org slash giveaway i love these guys
i've read city journal for years
i think that for a long time they've put
out tremendous stuff and they're still
putting out
really really great stuff some of the
some of the most important
reporting and commentary out there head
on over to city journal today
so we're we're hearing from the federal
government that you got to get this
vaccine get it as soon as you can you'll
pay the price if you don't but but yet
from the federal agencies
we're not really seeing that being
implemented because if if truly we all
need to get the vaccine
then that means that we've got to have a
vaccine passport or your employers have
the right to ask for it your
your businesses that you frequent have
the right to ask for it everybody does
the government has the right to ask for
it but that's not what we're seeing
the department of justice according to
reports
will not ask employees to confirm their
vaccination status
after allowing them to go maskless
indoors following updated guidelines
from the cdc
according to a report now ad from the
hill so
they were initially suggesting that they
would force employees
to confirm that they had been vaccinated
this would seem
to violate some norms and traditions in
this country this would seem to open
them up to litigation and so they're not
going to do it
we heard this news yesterday starbucks
and walmart are going to open up their
stores
uh to the unmasked and the policy is
if you're vaccinated you don't need a
mask if you were unvaccinated you do
need a mask but they're not going to
check
so effectively what this means is
everyone's going to take the mask off
and
it just shows you the conflicting
propaganda we've got
on the one hand covet is so super-duper
serious
that we've got to wear masks even as we
walk from
the the receptionist to the the hostess
stand to our dinner table at a
restaurant
it's so super duper dangerous that we've
got to wear that mask then but we can
take it off at the table
well why because you can't eat with a
mascot well
so why is the restaurant open in the
first place well because it's not that
dangerous if it were really
as dangerous as they're they were all
saying it is then they should just keep
the restaurants closed
but they didn't do that so you're
getting such conflicting
messages here and that's why people i
think increasingly are tuning them out
which is perfectly fine
as far as i'm concerned speaking of
controversial scientific claims
we're getting a really controversial
claim from the nfl
as it tries to stave off lawsuits from
people who have been injured
playing in the league so
get a load of this one this is really
quite politically incorrect
the nfl which has gone very very woke in
recent years
which has in many ways led the country
in disrespecting the american flag
in the protest of the star-spangled
banner because of
white supremacy and how they stand for
black lives matter
so the nfl is reportedly trying to stave
off a one
billion dollar brain injury settlement
fund and claims made on that fund
by arguing that blacks are stupider than
whites
that is one of the arguments that is
being made so this accusation right now
is being made by former redskins
oops am i allowed to say that term i
know that we're what are they called now
they're called the washington football
team
this is the most vague bland name ever
i'm going to stick with redskins i think
the former redskins running back ken
jenkins
just delivered 50 000 petitions to the
billion dollar
funds administrator uh senior u.s
district
judge anita brody and uh jenkins is is
highlighting something here which is
that you've got to prove that you've had
cognitive impairment
in order to be entitled for some of this
settlement fund
or entitled to it rather and so you got
to show that your
your brain has dropped below the
average performance here what would be
expected but there's a two-tiered system
apparently in in here
because what the nfl is allegedly
arguing
is that black people ordinarily have
lower cognitive
skills than white people so they're so
on the one
hand the nfl is arguing we're black
lives matter we're so supportive
yeah let's protest the flag down with
white supremacy and then out of the
other side of their mouth they're saying
but actually you know blacks are dumber
than whites
now they're saying those both at the
same do you see the conflicting message
do you see why this tarnishes the
credibility
of not just the credibility of public
health people but credibility of
allegedly woke institutions like
the nfl really ugly stuff really bad pr
for them
obviously i haven't seen every detail of
every legal document here but
this is the claim being made by by ken
jenkins
and one suspects that the nfl is going
to want to tamp down this publicity so
let's see
let's see if they can answer for it
speaking of locker rooms
tennessee my wonderful state my home
state of tennessee it's my new home but
it's my home nonetheless
they are have now passed a law that will
put
schools at risk of lawsuits if
they let men into the girls locker room
or into the girls bathrooms any gender
bending rule like that
tennessee governor bill lee has just
signed this bill
that will open the schools up to
punishment
if they permit transgender students
meaning men who are pretending to be
women or vice versa
use locker rooms that do not reflect
their quote
gender at birth so this is a phrase
being used in the reporting here
their gender at birth oh this is great
legislation i'm very glad that
tennessee is standing up for the women's
room you know i'm glad i didn't know
that we would need to elect rock ribbed
conservatives to stand up for the ladies
room but but apparently we have to
uh we've really got to watch our
language here too folks because
you're going to hear reporting on this
and say it refers to transgender
students singles out transgender
students
transgenderism is not a thing it's a
social phenomenon
but it isn't real what is contained
in the phrase transgenderism is the
belief that a man can really be a woman
but that isn't true a man cannot really
be a woman and so transgenderism
as a concept is a fantasy lock that away
with the easter bunny and the tooth
fairy
that isn't real we should stop using
that phrase another phrase i hear from
conservatives a lot
is this phrase biological males
if you maybe you've used it yourself i
know it look it's tricky
the left lays all these linguistic traps
for us and very often we fall into those
traps
but this is a very bad idea because it
advances the left's purpose a process
that i write about at great length in my
upcoming book speechless controlling
words controlling minds which is
available now for pre-order you can also
pre-order the audio book we i just
finished
recording the audio book it's available
on audible and other places you can
pre-order that as well thank you to
everyone who's pre-ordered
i think there are a lot of conservatives
who believe that by being really
specific
they're going to outfox the left so the
left says
i'll use caitlyn jenner as an example
that caitlyn jenner is a trans woman
and a trans woman is refers to a man who
now pretends to be a woman and so
now he's a trans woman and when
conservatives don't want to go along
with that kind of jargon they'll say
actually you know
caitlyn jenner is a biological male
now they think they're being very
specific here but they're actually
accepting the whole premise
the whole premise of transgenderism
because if you use the phrase biological
male you're implying that there's some
other kind of male
that you can be a non-biological male
which is the whole idea of
transgenderism
so we i think we can't do it folks i
know we're trying to be polite
we're trying to be specific but if you
wanted to be
most specific and by the way if you want
to be most respectful
by telling people the truth instead of
lies then you got to drop the qualifier
he's a man baby he's a man i sound like
austin powers it's just a man
you'll notice that political correctness
often uses this formula actually the
very phrase politically correct uses
this formulation
where you put an adverb before
an adjective to not just transform but
actually
negate the adjective what i mean by that
is you got something like correct what
is correct mean it means true
but then you've got the phrase
politically correct and politically
correct is ironic because
the politically negates the correct
politically correctness means not true
this this was mocked in its in pc's
early days as
as the formulation of the adverbially
adverbially pre-modified adjectival
lexical unit
right because that's the way the jargon
sounds it's this kind of silly language
that that either obscures or more often
outright negates
the meaning so don't do it you know
we're kind of slow on the uptake here we
like to consider ourselves
pretty sturdy conservative we love
freedom we're
blunt here in america but we're not
we're not actually believe it or not
france
is doing a better job on this issue than
we are the
freaking french are more conservative
on this issue than the americans are
france is right now
banning the use of gender
neutral language in schools so
there was a push a couple weeks ago to
include full stops in the middle of
written words
they'll call this midpoints which would
there therefore allow
both male and female forms to be
represented simultaneously
you know france french is a gendered
language just like
italian and just like spanish like the
romance languages right the
la biblioteca in spanish is a female
uh word ends in an a it
accepts the the article la right there
there are male words and female words
this is actually what gender referred to
it just referred to grammar
until the 1960s when uh the use of
gender as referring to sex was
popularized and that's where we got the
sex gender distinction
that sent us down this crazy rabbit hole
but the french came out they said no
and what what the french officials came
out and said was
that if you use this sort of thing you
will actually butcher the french
language
they actually saw this as a colonization
by the english by the americans of
france that
that wokeness that pc is a form actually
of imperialism how ironic we're told
that the whole point of
wokeness and pc is to decolonize the
white supremacy actually what does it do
to is actually colonizing
every other culture now
where can you learn all of these sorts
of arcane
really behind the scenes historical
things
you can check out a great podcast from
wondering wondering's new podcast
mini-series
the vaping fix is a story of silicon
valley idealism
blind ambition and how the now infamous
e-cigarette company jewel
hooked a new generation on vaping in
2015
the founders of joules set out to create
the ipod of e-cigarettes
a perfectly designed device that would
disrupt the tobacco industry
and help traditional smokers quit but
their fruit-flavored vaping options high
levels of nicotine
and youthful influencer endorsements led
to consequences that would put millions
at risk
as plumes of vape clouds surrounded
schools across the nation
parents politicians and the government
demanded answers was this jules plan
all along or did ambition blind them
from seeing the pitfalls of their
invention
hosted by laura beale and from the team
behind dr death
and bad batch comes the vaping fix
listen to the vaping fix
on amazon music apple podcasts or you
can also listen early
and add free by starting your free trial
of wondering plus
in the wondery app you know not everyone
has the privilege of getting to know the
one and only
candace owens live and in person who did
did candace write this copy
this is very very flattering you know
though you you might be able to meet her
you might seriously not just because i'm
going to hook it up don't text me and
twice can you
no here's how you can do it if you sign
up as a daily wire member with code vip
you will get 20 off your new membership
and be automatically entered for a
chance to win a trip to the daily wire
studios to see candace live
not only will you be meeting canvas
you'll be getting an inside look at her
studio
our office and front row seats to watch
her live and
in action on her talk show candace go
enter to win a candace vip pass right
now dailywire.com
subscribe use code vip for 20 off
and for an experience that only joe
biden could forget
go check it out we'll be right back with
a lot more
i hate to say that the french have more
common sense than the americans but they
do
on this issue of wokeness i actually
when i was uh
researching my upcoming book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
available now for pre-order
i noticed that even in the pc debates of
the early 90s
the french said now we're not doing this
pc never
never infected france for all their
crazy radical leftist
liberal inclinations the french never
really went along with pc they're a very
politically
incorrect people and the point that the
french government is making right now
that natalie elimaz the state secretary
for priority education
pointing out that woke language is a
quote danger for our country
and the death knell for the use of
french in the world points out that
with the spread of inclusive writing
inclusive writing
the english language already
quasi-hegemonic across the world would
certainly and perhaps forever
defeat the french language that the woke
language is a creation
of the anglo-american culture
and when you when you go into other
languages notably those with gender
you're gonna you're going to impose a
sort of cultural tyranny on them you see
it with the word la tinx
you know now it's very popular to call
mexicans and guatemalans and
every first of all you've got to lump
them all together there's no distinction
anymore to be had between
guatemalans and hondurans and
nicaraguans and mexicans and there's no
distinction whatsoever they're all just
the same it used to be hispanic
then it was latino but then latino
that's a male term so now it's got to be
la tinx you say wait a second
words don't end that way in the spanish
language so now we're imposing
english linguistic structures on
on a foreign culture all in the name of
decolonization
very crazy we should learn something
from the french never thought i would
utter that phrase
speaking of political correctness abroad
swim across that little english channel
out of france to england
where the royal family is facing a woke
problem of its own prince
harry you know prince harry all he wants
is privacy
all he wants is to be out of the media
spotlight which is why he just goes on
as many podcasts as he possibly can
poor aggrieved harry harry just recently
went on a show
to viciously attack his family once
again in
harsher terms than he has even today and
to decry what he considers to be
a genetic cycle of abuse
there's a lot of genetic pain and
suffering that gets passed on anyway
yeah as parents we should be doing the
most what we can to try and say
you know what that happened to me i'm
gonna make sure that doesn't happen to
you i never saw it i never knew about it
and then suddenly i started to piece it
all together and go
okay so this is where he went to school
this is what happened i know this bit
about his life
i also know that's connected to his
parents yeah so
that means that he's treating me the way
that he was treated exactly
which means how can i change that for my
own kids and well
here i am i've now moved my whole family
to the us
that wasn't the plan but sometimes
you've got to make decisions
and put your family first and put your
mental health first oh my gosh this is
so embarrassing this man
is a combat veteran this man this was a
tough guy
from a family devoted to duty and
responsibility whose old purpose is to
serve the country
and now he's whining about mental health
and to the way his father was raised and
his father was raised poorly too by the
way this guy's grandfather just
died prince philip after what was it 97
or 99 years of public service
he finally dies after giving his life to
his adopted country
and what does this ingrid do he comes
out and he says yeah he was a horrible
father to my father and my father was a
horrible father to me and i'm i'm really
wonderful
you know i'm a good person which is why
i abandoned my family and my country and
my duty and fled to
gamora by the sea out in california how
pathetic this is it's it's very
unmanly and unseemly to whine
this is true for anybody i don't care
everybody's got problems okay one of my
favorite lines
is from the tennessee williams plate
orpheus descending
where the the derelict is trying to
shack up with
a lady and he's trying to you know spend
the night at her place
and she won't have it and he says but
i've got nowhere to go and she says well
everybody's got a problem and that's
yours
i love that line everybody's got a
problem and that's yours you know
there's very popular advice which is
when you're dealing with people you know
just be aware they might be going
through a lot they might have a lot of
inner turmoil so
have sympathy and empathy for them i
totally agree i think that's very
important advice
be don't be cruel to people
now i sound like elvis don't be cruel
good advice
you should treat every interaction with
someone as though you might not get to
see him again
very important i know that i know the
vaccine saves and it's going to give us
all immortality but
uh that probably that's not going to
happen so yes
be empathic be kind to people be
charitable
but the flip side of that is everybody's
got a problem
and you got yours and they got theirs
and sometimes you got to man
up and quit whining and and quit blaming
your parents for all of your problems
well you know but i had really terrible
parents they wouldn't even take me to
the country castle every weekend when i
wanted them to yeah
well you know boohoo buddy sorry just
man up for goodness sakes i think so
many of our political problems come
from this problem because the family
contrary to popular
leftist propaganda the family is in a
sense private
right it is protected against the
predations of the state
but in a sense it's public because the
family is the bedrock political
institution
it's where politics begins it's where
society begins it's the fundamental unit
of society
and as the family breaks down as people
have no respect for their families
for their parents they will have no
respect for their broader
community if i don't respect my own
family why am i going to respect the
family of the guy
two blocks down the street why am i
going to respect the family
of the guy two states away why am i
going to respect my country more broadly
patriotism is an extension of filial
piety
so if we lose the ladder we're going to
lose the former and that's what's
happening
i mean you you have harry actually this
is the perfect example of this he's
deriding his own country and his
or his own family rather and his family
is the symbol of the country
they are the royal family of the uk
but this is true at a smaller scale for
all of us
and brits are saying very stupid things
these days they are
they are you know i love our anglo
motherland you know i i even like the
royal family
those german interlopers i even like
them i do i
really like queen elizabeth but some
brits are saying really really stupid
things such as
john oliver it occurred to me the other
day that john oliver
is consistently vulgar
his version of a joke is just to say
some unfunny line and then yell the f
word or something in
in performative outrage right he does a
lot of that
and with reliable ignorance he never
really knows very much about anything
but he pretends to know a lot about he
has very little humility
and he yells and he shrieks and he says
the f word a bunch and that's supposed
to pass for a joke
so in a way the performative outrage
the reliable ignorance the
absolute haughtiness and vulgarity
john oliver might be the voice of a
generation i think he really sums it all
up
and now oliver is weighing in
on israel-palestine a sort of hack tv
comedian
is finally going to clear up on one of
the longest standing
geopolitical religious and problems in
the history of the world
all right solve it for me john both
sides are firing rockets
but one side has one of the most
advanced militaries in the world
both sides are suffering heartbreaking
casualties but
one side is suffering them exponentially
and it's not like the us is operating
from the moral high ground here it's
obviously
no stranger to drone striking weddings
and saying we were just trying to target
enemy combatants this country has blood
on its hands too and look
if you believe israel's actions are
warranted and proportioned it this week
you're welcome to try and make that
argument but we have
got to start having this conversation
honestly and falling back on
convenient sanitized terms like real
estate disputes and
air strikes on militants feels a little
disingenuous
when what you're describing is forcing
people from the homes they've lived in
for decades
and killing civilians and children and
again
none of this frees hamas from
responsibility but hamas
doesn't represent all palestinians just
as what israel is doing right now
doesn't represent all israelis or indeed
jewish people
lots is complicated here but some things
are pretty simple one side is suffering
much
more so there is a lot of
philosophical confusion here that john
oliver has and
just even the point of war and how one
responds to aggressors
and the distinction between terrorism
and and justified
state violence we'll get into that in a
second but he's also just made a claim
that is
is absurd on its face namely he says
that hamas doesn't represent the
palestinian people
but the thing is it does hamas got
elected by the palestinian arabs so if
you believe in any way
in self-government democracy then
hamas very much represents
the so-called palestinians
just like the government of bibi
netanyahu represents
the people of israel it does
and so if if people don't like
if people in palestine don't like the
way hamas is acting they shouldn't have
elected them
but they did elect them and now they're
facing the consequences
also the idea that israel if if
hamas sends a rocket over and kills five
israeli
civilians targeting the civilians the
idea that israel
should respond by only targeting
five i guess well they no one would
suggest that israel should target five
arab civilians but so
i think there the argument falls apart
already but but even the idea that
israel should only target five
hamas operatives is insane that's not
how war works
you don't just say okay we're gonna
you're just gonna kill one of me and
i'll kill one of you and then five and
five and five and five until what until
it goes on forever
now the point of war is to defeat your
enemy
that war is the extension of politics by
other means right
so unless you want there to be a
stalemate forever which will lead to
far more suffering and death and misery
then someone's got to win no one wants
to win wars anymore though
i mean even the way america wages wars
now we're not permitted to win them
anymore
we used to be permitted to win them we
obviously would win them militarily
we're the greatest
military force ever in the history of
the world but the political forces here
mostly coming from the left will not
permit that sort of thing because it's
considered icky or yucky or somehow
wrong
to defeat an enemy particularly
when the enemy is considered to be less
powerful but the reason that the less
powerful enemy feels justified
and confident in picking on the far more
powerful enemy in this case
hamas picking on israel is because they
know
that israel will not be permitted to
defeat them
so you've got you're john oliver is
right in saying that this is a complex
situation
but his argument what is his argument
here that the answer is
to give the palestinian arabs a
nation-state well the palestinian
arabs elected a group that explicitly is
calling for the destruction of israel so
israel can't tolerate that anybody who
thinks israel has a right to exist
or even that it is preferable that
israel exists can't tolerate that sort
of thing
what what i don't even know what his
argument is
other than all these muddled uh
philosophical premises that
that representative government isn't
legitimate i guess he he denied
representative government
he denied that people have the right to
win war when they're when they have war
waged upon them and if he's supporting
us a so-called palestinian nation he's
denying
the right of israel to exist so okay
then go out and make that argument he's
not making that argument because he
doesn't know what he's saying he's just
yelling
profanity and and performing his outrage
but the people who yell a lot and who
use a lot of profanity usually do so
because their arguments aren't
particularly sound
speaking of shills for hamas uh andy no
perhaps the last journalist in america
just uh posted a video
of some pro-palestine hoodlums who were
going around
breaking into a youtuber's family's home
because the youtuber apparently defended
israel and this really irritated
the palace palestine sympathizers
this was a dirty dog who disrespect our
brothers and sisters of palestine
yeah there you go smashing up the
windows light goes on on the upper floor
these lunatic hoodlums coming in
breaking more windows
filming it too like a bunch of bunch of
dopes
now smacking the nice car
you hear people screaming in the house
and now they enter the house
look at that look at these criminals
entering the house
videos like this scenes like this really
really make me
happy that i'm an american because in
america we have a second amendment
if they had a second amendment in the uk
you wouldn't see as many scenes like
this
because if a group of people entered my
house like this frankly even if they
just started throwing things
they would be blown to smithereens
because people have the right to defend
themselves i guess that
i guess that's a lot of what this
conflict in the middle east is boiling
down to right now too
whether or not and how people have the
right to defend themselves and against
whom
but but this is the the side that people
are aligned with you know there's so
much propaganda coming out right now
especially from the left on against
israel but really just israel to them as
an avatar for the west
generally they consider israel to be a
sort of colony of
of the west and the middle east which
they think really should belong to
arab muslims or something to that effect
and
uh the more videos like that come out
and the more
the uh details of what's of what's
really going on in this conflict come
out
i think the the clearer it is
any side that has those pro-palestinian
pro-hamas hoodlums
breaking into innocent people's homes
and has john oliver on it frankly i
don't know which one's worse
i'm just very likely not going to be on
that side
we're talking a lot about bullies
bullies in the government bullies in
the media bullies on the global stage
so i have assiduously avoided learning
anything about chrissy teigen i just
i'm very very proud that i don't really
know anything about chrissy teigen
and i've told people i don't want to
know any i don't think that my life
would improve
by knowing who chrissy teigen is you
know i know she's being canceled or
something
like that and she's got uh now i know
she's got a line at some department
store then i learned she's married to
john legend i still don't really know
who john legend is apparently he's a
either a musician or an actor or
something so now i know that i wish i
didn't know that
and they're both apparently you know
huge left-wingers and they're always
calling on other people to stop being
hateful and mean and they're calling for
empathy and all this stuff
and then it turns out i'm sorry to say i
now know kind of who she is
because she has been exposed
for saying vicious horrible things to
some woman this woman named courtney
stodden who apparently received all
these insane messages
vicious vile messages from chrissy
teigen telling her even to kill herself
and this is a woman
courtney stodden who apparently has a
history of mental problems and actually
attempted to commit suicide
here is stauden describing the verbal
abuse
i just couldn't believe how hypocritical
it was um hypocrisy tegan
hip-hop chrissy teigen um it was just so
hypocritical of her
um i think for me like because i
experienced so much
harassment and bullying from her
when i was just 16 years old it really
affected me and i think the bottom line
is i never had a chance to forgive her
i think like i've never really she
she's never given me a chance to to
forgive her
and i guess forgiveness right starts
with ourselves but it's so
damaging when you have somebody like
chrissy teigen
bullying children so i take it this gal
was younger she was a teenager or
something when this began
and the messages were really really vile
and so now this woman is being canceled
and that's perfectly fine i mean you
know that my my view on cancer culture
is not it's not exactly the same view
that a lot of
right wingers are pushing a lot of
people are making the mistake on the
right
of saying that cancel culture is
terrible because we need to be free
speech absolutists
and we need to oppose censorship in the
abstract all the time and
and we need to never limit what people
say and i think that's total bs i'm all
for it man get
let's cancel more people i love it you
know in the 1950s we canceled communists
awesome we should we should have kept
doing that i wish we continued to do
that
we cancelled obscenity in this country
for many
many decades for centuries we're still
supposed to do it on the books but we
don't do it as much we should do that
sort of thing
that compromises our freedom so i'm all
for that and i'm all for people
facing consequences but i i just don't
want people to have their lives ruined
for saying
ordinary normal mainstream things or for
minor transgressions that that or even
more significant transgressions that
people repent
i'm all for cancelling
unrepentant people who are pushing bad
things i think that's perfectly fine
there is obviously hypocrisy here but i
just when i
saw the story when i actually finally
delved into who chrissy teigen is and
what this
issue is between these two women
it rang so true because you see this so
much from the left
the people who talk about stopping hate
and love trump's hate we've got to stop
the bullying and the meanness and the
hatred and the intolerance
they are always with without exception
the most hateful the most bigoted the
least tolerant people that you ever see
and it's because of
i think these two religions i think it
gets back right down to what we were
talking about at the top of the show
there's the religion of christ the
redeemer with the arms outstretched and
there's the religion of
fouchy the redeemer with with the
vaccine saves written on it and
one is is true religion christianity and
the other
is the secular liberal religion of
scientism
and there one is based on humility one
is based on
pride right one is based on the
complexity and fallenness and brokenness
of the world and one is based on
this utopian scheme that through
scientific rationalism we're going to
create the perfect world and fix human
nature and cure death even right
one is based on a recognition of our
mortality one one is based on
the the pursuit of immortality here on
earth
uh those are those are different
religions one time i got a call
from a guy that i went to college with
who i didn't really keep up with and we
weren't particularly close
especially in later years i rarely saw
him and
he was a big leftist and he
he got in trouble he committed a really
bad crime really
about as bad as it gets and he reached
out to me
i thought why are you reaching out to me
i don't barely even know this guy that
well
and uh he said you know i always thought
because you're politics and it's school
i was an atheist when i was in college
but
but politically i was still right-wing
and he said you know i always thought
you were a big jerk because you're
politics but i was reaching out
to see if you have any advice and just
to tell you my problem
and i thought that's strange this but
then it kind of clicked into me
in the in the really shallow sense
conservatives
christians we're the most judgmental
people we are
we will we will look caitlyn jenner
right in the eyes and say you are not a
woman and i won't call you she
you can't get me to lie i'm not going to
do it not going to go along
right in the in the very shallow sense
we're extremely judgmental we're making
judgments about the world
we're not tolerant of of many things but
in the broader sense
when when the tough times come
we're by far the most tolerant people
the conservatives and the christians are
much much more tolerant and open-minded
than the leftists the leftists are far
crueler far more narrow-minded here
because their vision of humanity is just
wrong they have a false anthropology
they don't seem to have a whole lot of
sense of mercy for people
and what matters to them is what they
say much more than what they do this is
also a premise of political correctness
the grace goes away because their their
world view is a world
without grace right i mean this is why
they're so angry this is why they're
entitled this is why they're resentful
and i don't just mean this as personal
flaws that everybody has to some degree
i mean that that is the ideology right
this is what you know blm and knocking
down the statues and
badmouthing your own family on podcasts
like prince harry's doing that's the
ideology
whereas for the conservatives the
philosophy is based primarily in our own
brokenness and our humility
and our own need for grace and the grace
that we've received on merited
we one would hope would give to someone
else very
clearly summed up in the lord's prayer
forgive us our sins as we forgive those
who
who trespass against us that's what
we're
that's what we're asking for here those
are those are two different
visions of the world and as we as we
exalt the one
as we put as we put dr fauci on christ
the redeemer's head
in rio de janeiro we are we are
necessarily going to lose the other and
that
that sort of propaganda is the sort of
thing that would be very very difficult
to come back from that is a much uglier
much stupider much less pleasant society
i'm michael nolan's the michael knowles
show
see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boary our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadofsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021 on the matt wall show we talk about
the things that matter real issues that
affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show